but isn't it on America and wrong to
discriminate against people based on
their religion but Julie is a problem we
have people coming into our country that
are looking to do tremendous harm you
look at the to look at Paris look at
what happened in Paris I mean these
people they did not come from Sweden
okay look at what happened in Paris look
at what happened last week in California
with with you know 14 people dead other
people going to die they're so badly
injured I mean we have a real problem
there's a tremendous hatred out there
and what I want to do is find out what
it you know you can't solve a problem
until you find out what's the root cause
and I want to find out what is the
problem what's going on and it's
temporary I've had so many people call
me and say thank you now if you remember
when I did that a week ago it was like
bedlam all of a sudden and you watch
last night and you see people talking to
saying well Trump has a point we have to
get down to the problem the people that
are friends of mine they call they said
Donald you've done us a tremendous
service because we do have a problem and
we have to find out those - crank calls
those may have been grateful one of the
things I find fascinating about Donald
Trump is the way he uses language
differently than other candidates for
political office especially President of
the United States whereas his opponents
and the political class in general seem
hyper aware that their words will be
picked apart and used against them Trump
willfully disregards this fact as a
lifelong salesman he has a hucksters
knack for selling a feeling even if the
ideas and facts that underscore it are
spurious racist are just plain
incomprehensible so I thought it would
be illuminating to look at a Trump
answer to a simple question in this case
Jimmy Kimmel asking Trump whether or not
it's wrong to discriminate against
people based on their religion referring
to Trump's proposal to temporarily ban
all Muslims from entering the United
States
this 220 word exactly one minute answer
displays I think a range of the things
that Trump uses all the time in his
speech the first thing to note is how
simple this languages of the 220 words a
hundred and seventy two or seventy-eight
percent are only one syllable and often
they come in a rhythmic series like a
volley of jabs ending with one of his
buzz words we have to get down to the
property nine words or 17 percent are
two syllables long only four words have
three syllables three of which are the
word tremendous tremendous tremendous
and just two words are four syllables
long California which he's forced to use
because it has less syllables than San
Bernardino and temporary which he
swallows and each temperate I've had so
many people this breakdown fits with the
study done by the Boston Globe that put
all 2016 presidential candidates
announcement speeches through the flesh
Kincaid readability test to determine
their respective grade level rankings
Donald Trump's speech came out at a
fourth grade reading level now for
reference Ben Carson came out at sixth
grade Hillary Clinton and Jeb Bush were
speaking at an eighth grade reading
level and Bernie Sanders was a way up in
high school a sophomore to be exact
now this isn't only down to word or
syllable choice it's about sentence
construction too Trump favors simple
sentences like and we have a real
problem there's a tremendous hatred out
there rarely does he use complex
sentences or independent clauses he also
favors the second person a lot of the
time addressing listeners directly with
commands look at Paris look at what
happened in Paris look at what happened
in Paris look at what happened last week
in California or implicating us in what
he's saying as if we've already agreed
and you watch last night and you see
people talking he's really good at this
at framing negative response as an
overreaction that was subsequently
realized as such if you remember when I
did that a week ago I was like bedlam
all of a sudden and you watched last
night and you see people talking to say
well Trump has a point we have to get
down to the problem may be the most
important technique Trump utilizes and
he does this more than anyone I've ever
heard
is ending his sentences with strong
punchy words a lot of times he'll
rearrange the beginning of a sentence
awkwardly so that he can end strong for
example here it would probably be more
natural to say you can't solve a problem
until you find out what the root cause
is but he brings the is forward to end
on root cause he does the same here and
it looks like that's what he was about
to do at the end before Kimball cuts him
off these final words are crucial for
Trump they're pointed and taken together
sketch the theme of the entire answer
arm dead die badly injured problem route
cars Thank You Ted Lapointe rival
service problem in some sense it's these
words that audiences remember especially
when the rest of his speech is
incoherent like the best salesman Trump
keeps it simple he repeats a lot we have
a real problem what is the problem we do
have a problem we have to get down to
the problem and he uses his favorite
words over and over tremendous
tremendous tremendous service and he
always seems to have friends who are
part of the group that he's currently
insulting calling him up and thanking
him for the privilege many of them
called me and they said you know Donald
you're right we have a problem there is
a problem Donald Trump knows when to
sound incredulous or forceful he has
good comedic instinct you could even
call him witty but you can't call him
smart or well-informed the best salesman
could sell you a TV without knowing
anything about it
because the TV isn't what matters what
matters is you and if you are an
American citizen who for years has
listened to politicians sound
sophisticated while accomplishing
nothing
you might just be primed for something
that is everything they are not but the
next time you feel like Donald Trump has
a point
do yourself a favor and look at his
words
hey everybody thanks for watching I want
to point you in the direction of my
friends over at wisecrack who do some
awesome work some awesome video essays
if you like my stuff you're definitely
like what they do they talk about books
movies and my personal favorite is
definitely 8-bit philosophy which is
like philosophy explained with Nintendo
graphics so well done I wish I'd thought
of that anyway go over there click there
subscribe watch a video if you guys want
to help me out as always you can click
right here pledge a dollar or three
dollars or five dollars to my channel
help me start 2016 right we're gonna do
some awesome stuff in the next year I
can't wait to see you guys next
Wednesday for the next video and I will
see you well I just set up in the see
you next Wednesday so so bye